well do you remember 20 minutes ago when
the decision by the United Kingdom the
British to leave the European Union
brexit it's called was going to cause
the world to come to an end and the
stock market was going to crash and
world economies were going to implode do
you remember that 20 minutes ago was
three weeks ago remember oh the Dow
Jones Industrial Average set another
record yesterday remember that the next
time the evening news is in drama mode
and they're trying to scare you into
oblivion into the corner sucking your
thumb so that you clean out your 401k
because they'd are your financial
advisors they're stupid remember that
because we were on here telling you
don't cash out your stuff it's going to
be okay as a matter of fact the long
term net result of the British leaving
the your opinions probably good for not
only the British but for everyone else
economically speaking so because when
you don't have a bunch of people who
aren't managing money well telling you
how to manage your country it works
better think about it
it's really not rocket science this from
a country who has 19 trillion dollars in
debt but what do I know
okay so but you're okay you're okay
you're not going to die and every time
they come on the news with a new foe
crisis foes a fancy word for false not
real pretend made-up not a crisis but
they need something to talk about to
scare you out of your freaking minds so
that you jump on facebook and buy gold
stop it see I have to go back after
these events and say I told you so
occasionally so that the next time you
have a you know what we around here when
we have a tech guys when I was meeting
with some of my tech guys today they
said you know we went through this and
our learnings are this I that's a new
that's a technical talk I guess or maybe
it's fancy corporate talk I don't know
but learnings we had learnings meaning
we learned some crap
from walking through that so you walk
through brexit you walk through 2008 you
walk through any other little hiccup
that that you know Chinese economy
catches the flu and we decide we all
have it and you know you learn from all
these hiccups that aren't quote unquote
newsworthy affecting the stock market
that it's a really dumb idea to try to
jump in and out of the market based on
the emotions of the evening news anchor
they're transferring into your living
room if that's your financial advisor
you're going to be broke your whole
freaking life those of us that have
learned to invest and the good times and
in the bad times you know when I invest
every month every month for decades you
know what it turns into millions of
dollars it's just this magical thing so
and and you know how you don't get
millions of dollars you start and stop
you start and stop you start and stop
based on the emotions of crap like
brexit and the evening news so this is
your learnings for the day your teaching
for the day don't follow the roller
coaster ride ride the roller coaster
don't let your broke friends conspiracy
theories about the trilateral commission
and the Denver Airport keep you from
actually investing into stuff long term
these are broke people giving their
financial opinions keep that in mind you
need to think about that that's like a
fat person telling you how to work out
it's not a good plan okay so think about
it think about it think about it think
about think about think about think
about if you had not sold in 2008 when
Dow went from 14 down to 6,000 $14,000
6,000 what if you had not sold and
bought all the way down understand those
dollars that you spent at 6,000 when the
Dow is 18,000 now do you understand that
means your money's tripled so if I put
in a million dollars at the bottom I now
have 3 million on that one transaction
that's pretty cool putting a hundred
thousand and three and a thousand I put
in a dollar
three dollars and that's you know but
you know we didn't know where the bottom
was but I invested all the way down and
all the way up and here we sit at 18,000
and some change heading towards 19,000
pretty quick so it is it always going up
over time for a hundred years yes
has it always gone down yes temporarily
pretty regularly but it's a temporary
measure so I have millions of dollars
tied up in investments and mutual funds
and 401ks millions of dollars tied up in
investments in real estate that I paid
cash for and you know why it's Millions
because I've done it over over over over
over over over and over it's just boring
is correct
you got nothing cool to tell your
friends about you can't go you know
about this stock and it went up because
I never did I buy mutual funds and it's
like boring I'm a really boring dinner
partner when if you want to talk about
investments because I only do two things
I just over and over and over and over
and over and over I buy real estate and
I almost never sell it I've actually got
one piece of property up for sale right
now for the first time in 20 years I
actually got a piece of property I'm
willing to sell and not not dying to
give it away but I just got some other
stuff I'd rather do with that money and
a different deal and so I'm going to go
ahead and take care of that if while the
markets high maybe if somebody wants to
buy it bad enough so far we'll see but I
don't bottle sell anything I just buy I
haven't cashed out mutual funds and
forever unless I moved them into real
estate I've never well unless I moved
into the real estate in ten years I've
not used any money out of a mutual fund
over ten years I never take it out I
just invested and build it and build it
and build it and build it and build it
and build it and that enables us then to
be able to give like maniacs without
rageous generosity it enables us to live
a life that is unbelievable because of
that simple discipline of overtime
Steven Covey used to tell the story of
the Chinese bamboo tree when you plant a
Chinese bamboo tree
you tend it and you fertilize around it
and you weed around it you water it in
the first year nothing happens does not
break through the ground the second year
you tend it in your fertilizer round and
you weed around nothing happens two
years you have seen nothing three years
you see nothing
four years of tending the seed in the
ground with the Chinese bamboo tree you
see nothing in the fifth year it grows
80 feet
that's how money works you just do you
just do what you're supposed to do even
if you're not seeing big results it's
not sexy it's not cool there's no
pyrotechnics you just beat it to death
you just invest and invest vast vast
vast vast good times and in bad times
and when they start screaming like a
beagle chasing a rabbit on the evening
news you turn it off you ever heard them
sounds ridiculous and the ridiculous
thing is is we let them set the tone for
our lives
a beagle chasing a rabbit this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or a five hundred
thousand dollar income
you